turning now to washington where the
house select committee investigating the
january 6th assault is collecting new
information for more public hearings
this month in a series of interviews
members of the committee now say they
recommend that former president trump
and others should face criminal charges
for the attack scott mcfarland is on
capitol hill
scott good morning
ed good morning to you the committee
investigating the u.s capitol attack
says more witnesses are coming forward
even as its members talk openly about
something never done before
a formal recommendation of a criminal
prosecution against a former u.s
president
nearly 18 months after the siege of the
u.s capitol vice chair of the january 6
select committee liz chaney says
multiple criminal referrals to federal
prosecutors are being considered and
that former president trump shouldn't be
excluded the justice department doesn't
have to wait for the committee to make a
criminal referral
and there could be more than one
criminal referral in its next hearing
expected later this month the committee
will focus on the alleged role of
far-right groups including the proud
boys and oath keepers who was
participating who was financing it how
it was organized
we obviously want to probe any
connection between these dangerous
groups and the white house
in her testimony last week former white
house aide cassidy hutchinson said she
heard references to the far-right groups
in white house discussions ahead of the
6th
i recall
hearing
the word oath keeper and hearing the
word proud boys
closer to the planning of the january 6
rally when mr giuliani would be around
following hutchinson's testimony members
of the committee revealed new witnesses
have emerged and might lead to more
testimony
every day we get new people that come
forward and say hey i didn't think maybe
this piece of a story that i knew was
important but now that you guys are like
i do see this plays in here
cbs news has learned donald trump's been
telling aides and allies he's seriously
considering announcing a 2024 white
house run as early as this summer even
as the committee continues to reveal
what it's uncovered about the former
president
glad
will certainly be interesting to see
which witnesses testify under oath next
scott thank you very much